[Applause]
this is the National Mall in Washington
DC more than 25 million people visit
annually at lunchtime on any given day
hungry tourists spill out onto the
[Music]
streets magic Naim the owner of the food
truck chicken friendly is feeding
[Music]
them from his spot in front of the
national museum Museum of American
history as he competes against dozens of
others in a parking
[Music]
freeall location is everything to keep
their prized spots vendors Park dummy
cars
overnight these trucks offer better
value than the pricey cafes of the
Smithsonian
museums right now customers are at the
National Mall and they're screaming out
for more food options attorney Justin
Pearson directs the national Street
vending initiative at the libertarian
legal nonprofit The Institute for
justice so it makes sense the food
trucks try to provide those food options
so that the food trucks can stay in
business and not lose their
dream the diversity is incredible the
food is so well cooked you can see they
really pour their hearts into it the
prices are extraordinary you can't beat
it these food trucks really have an
impact on people around here and you
know I just think they're good for the
community they face another challenge
these
[Music]
guys we are like struggling a little bit
with the tickets every day sometimes
it's $200 each day $300 each day so it's
not like a easy
here sometime the police bother us and
sometime I mean not sometime all the
time we get that like a t
tickets selling food from a truck along
the National Mall is technically illegal
that mattered less before Co because
there were other neighborhoods where
they were allowed to serve
lunch what was appealing was the
gratification you get when you have 50
people in line that are just dying to
try your food and they love it the
pandemic obviously closed all of the
Office Buildings trucks then had to find
other places to
vend the mall became the only spot in DC
with significant lunchtime foot
traffic so we work here in the National
Mall for just a tourist before Naim was
serving chicken fingers he raised live
chickens on a farm in Egypt he
eventually saved enough to buy his own
truck we hope everything go back back to
like a normal I don't have no nothing
else to do besides this business just
only the food truck business meanwhile
the fines rack up last year the city
collected
$467,000 in parking tickets along the
mall what's happening at the National
Mall is a real shame customers are being
ripped off by overpriced food sold at
the Museum's cafeterias and that problem
is directly a result of the lack of
competition it's ultimately a problem of
jurisdiction no nobody seems to want to
be take charge on the enforcement
Patrick Rathbone who's the owner of The
Big Cheese Truck used to serve the DC
lunch crowd now he focuses exclusively
on catering and special
events so the roads are DC uh
jurisdiction as from the sidewalk on is
National Park Service so they think the
National Park Service maybe should be
doing the enforcement so there's inner
bureaucracy like apathy I guess nobody
wants to be in charge of actually taking
care of of the trucks down there
[Music]
the National Park Service has resisted
calls from lawmakers to make vending
legal
there I think there has to be a meeting
between the DC folks and the National
Park Service DC can say we can solve the
parking and the illegal vending piece of
it but if we don't solve the transaction
side of things that's in your hands Park
Service it's not going to
[Music]
work with no compromise in sight food
truck operators remain stuck in the
middle and millions of visitors keep
coming to the mall every year looking
for a delicious and affordable
lunch
with officers waiting
nearby I see the future kind of like a
little bit difficult because if we still
get like buzzer from bar police and for
the tickets so I was thinking a lot to
leave this business to get something
else but for now I'm staying in this
business to see what's going
[Music]
on